it's rare to find a movie project that
doesn't accrue a thousandth as being
long conga line during casting but these
are the roles that some really famous
actors reject it it seems like no one in
Hollywood wanted these parts the true
hallmark of an actor's actor is the kind
who only does a movie because of an inch
a Keable interest in their characters
transformation over the course of a
narrative but the note books Noah
Calhoun has none of that growth he
begins the movie in love with the pretty
blond girl and ends up in love with the
same pretty blonde girl making the role
an unattractive one for most serious
actors this prompted most thespians to
pass on the part at least according to
Nicholas Sparks the author of the novel
that the film was based on this left the
door wide open for Ryan Gosling to slide
in and win over the world's heart than a
single romantic chick flick what do
Michelle Pfeiffer meg Ryan and Laura
Dern all have in common it turns out
these three actresses were all once on
the shortlist for the part of clarice
starling a role we now firmly associate
with Jodie Foster
thanks to her amazing performance in the
Silence of the Lambs
but foster only got the park because
Pfeiffer and Ryan rejected the script
with extreme prejudice due to a shared
distaste for the film's violent and
disturbed nature which director Jonathan
Demi revealed at an Austin Film Festival
interview so the script goes to meg Ryan
and word comes back very quickly like
good god I could never do a movie laughs
- she's slightly offended
while Demi wanted Dern for the part she
was relatively unknown at the time so he
ultimately went with foster at the
Gentle behest of the studio if you
thought the Lord of the Rings had a
substantial lack of Nicholas Cage in it
you're not the only one director Peter
Jackson thought Aragorn would be
perfectly portrayed by none other than
everyone's favorite national treasure
and Jackson also thought that Russell
Crowe would fit aragorn's lofty role
equally well also crossing Jackson's
mind as the perfect Aragorn
was none other than Daniel day-lewis as
you can tell Jackson had a lengthy wish
list of actors for this role but that
list didn't include Viggo Mortensen the
guy who ultimately landed the parts as
for why the previously mentioned actors
didn't work out
Kage didn't want franchise obligations
to distract from time with his kids
Crowe had prior commitments
and day-lewis never publicly stated his
reason thankfully Mortensen pulled off
the job just fine
when all is said and done the real
heroes of the Fifty Shades franchise are
the casting directors they are the brave
souls who had to wade through the bowels
of Hollywood to find a pair of actors
willing to denigrate themselves for the
adaptations of one of the most
embarrassing novel trilogies of all time
Fifty Shades of Grey was always destined
to be a kinky test in pain tolerance if
that pain was derived from permanent
career embarrassment the actors who
couldn't reject the role of billionaire
sadist Christian Grey fast enough
included Charlie Hunnam Garrett Hedlund
and Ryan Gosling okay any chance of
Fifty Shades of Grey everyone wants to
know I haven't what is this book that
everyone's talking about it seems very
popular as for the submissive end of the
casting spectrum the actresses who
weren't too keen on playing Anastasia
Steele included Lucy Hale Chloe Bridges
and Emma Watson the fight for who would
get the role of Michael Corleone was
actually a rather small scuffle fought
mainly between director Francis Ford
Coppola and his studio overheads the
studio petitioned hard for actors like
Martin Sheen and Jack Nicholson but
after Nicholson turned down the parts
and Coppola stood his ground the studio
is forced to entertain his desire to
cast Al Pacino in a 2004 interview with
movie line Nicholson explained his
decision by saying back then I believed
that Indians should play Indians and
Italians should play Italians Nicholson
sentiment turned out well for the film
but even Pacino didn't originally want
the part he knew that nobody wanted to
cast him except for Coppola whom Pacino
thought was a bit mad luckily Pacino in
the studio both came around similar to
50 shades of grey Twilight is another
case of an embarrassing book turning
into an embarrassing movie that no one
wanted to embarrass themselves by
starring in thus a list of actresses who
rejected the role of Bella Swan is no
surprise that list includes Emily
Browning Frances Bean Cobain and Emmy
Rossum the reasons range from general
disinterest to downright offense and how
bad the script was considering how the
poorly received finished product turned
out one can only imagine how grateful
they must be for their past selves well
warranted for sight
[Music]